Tom Brady just retired yeah yeah did you
feel anything about that so he's he's do
you know Tom
very Loosely all right but I have like a
long history with him because of where I
grew up like of course you know I uh
the good the bad the ugly like so he
first of all he wants the same school as
me Michigan so he's the same year okay
so oh really she remembers from college
yeah yeah so went to college with him
then he comes to the Pats and I'm I'm in
Boston and in the Patriots rise uh
really coincided with the bar stool rise
so we're so closely linked together
everything since I've been involved with
like the cops twice with Brady once in a
negative fashion once in well cops
involved is never good but one
anti-brady I guess you could say and one
pro like so he way back in the day uh
he he basically Giselle was on the beach
with their little kid Ben he was an
infant Ben Brady god wow uh and he was
naked who was Thomas no Ben the kid with
Gisele on a beach myself Beach Miami
naked too if I was with her yeah well
keep in mind the kid's an infant her son
oh okay so it's his son tiny little kid
like the Gerber baby oh wow huge dick
huge dick no way for a little baby and
you saw it how far away were you no it
was a [__] Paparazzi photo it was on
the internet and I could see that wand
on him yeah and I made a joke that going
deep this was the height of the Peyton
Manning Tom Brady like rivalry so I I
wrote a Blog in this one blog he said
check out the Howitzer on Brady's baby
and I wrote a sentence below I go Peyton
Manning could never have a kid with this
big of a hog or something like this
world war three broke out Dave's a
pedophile he's sexualizing kids the kid
was an infant police knocked on my door
and awesome came in like we're gonna
make your life real [__] horrible if
you don't take this down like people are
saying I should be beaten to death it
was oh it's like Mystic River it was
crazy so
that was way early and then fast forward
the Patriots explored we end up going to
jail defending Brady for when he got
suspended by the NFL handcuffed
ourselves to each other at NFL
Headquarters I've been dragged out of
the Super Bowl on handcuffs
um Bob Kraft the owner of the team when
Brady came back with Tampa Bay called me
up he's like I want you to be my guest
for when Brady comes back so it's been
the full circle and I have met him I
think a couple times
um but I like so if I saw him I'd be
like hey Tommy like hey Dave how's it
going good to see you but I don't know
him like on a real personal level but
yeah it's uh
their success and everything that
happened with the Patriots
I don't think Barstool probably is the
same if that doesn't happen it put us in
the headlines in a lot of different ways
so it's just a weird magical ride it
really has been it's been nuts
real fascinating man congratulations
just on getting to have that experience
because life you know to have the ups
and downs to have all of it you know to
really have so many experiences
football's so big in this country and
the Super Bowl's so big and we became
barcel of the face of like the Patriot
fan like there's a game they could
probably pull if you pull up like uh
Goodell clown towel so could tell a
commissioner in a league like the first
time he came back to uh Gillette after
all the controversy we printed like 70
000 of these towels with his face and a
nose and we we got we're like we need
volunteers to hand these things out
it was a big [__] thing like if you
you can if you on the images for it oh
yeah you'll see like the whole [__]
Stadium basically
oh
like go to the bottom right we had the
shirts so yeah like wow there you are
yeah so like the whole [__] Stadium
Goodell in there it just it was a wild
time and and we because people just they
hated us because people hated the
Patriots like but that was your thing
you did was it bar stools in here
there's like this infection it's like
this yeah it's almost like this like
this plague but it's not a negative
plague it's like this
disrupter yeah and the Patriots were the
most talked about hated loved whatever
team for like two decades oh yeah and
we're just right in the middle of it I
remember Tony Collins play there didn't
he was that Tony yeah you're going way
back yeah yeah running back yeah I I I
got to meet him one time he went to ECU
he's a cool cat man yeah I like Tony
Collins but I think he played in their
Super Bowl game that would have been 85
and they lost to the Bears man yeah yeah
wow yeah yeah yeah yup that was when the
Patriots they were very good that Steve
Grogan was like my guy he was like I
loved him yeah that I mean the Pacers
are for the most part terrible franchise
up to the Brady hour they had two Super
Bowls
um and the second one being the parcels
but like if you like Tech Mobile did you
ever play like oh yeah like they're the
worst team in Tech Mobile very sad I
can't even remember they had a lot of I
think one of the running back was white
I think even could have uh yeah Craig
James
half the Pony Express yeah I mean yeah
them in the Colts are the two worst
teams in it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one